I'm just gonna hijack my old bigram
because my circle is so beautifully
drawn you may like to draw another one
just a small one this one's not nearly
as complicated as that watch this circle
Shh this circle is now I'm defining it
I'm just finding it as the unit circle
okay so it has a radius of one so that a
pop of one in there okay now off of this
circle I'm going to draw a line that
will give me a triangle which is where
my 10 Peter and sec theta are going to
find their names okay not that
complicated so beat then I've sort of
used up the top half the diagram just
give use the bottom okay so if I join up
triangle or a cube okay by the way just
as a side note whenever you make any
statements about right-angled triangles
which I can now say this is because I
just proved that it's right into a
triangle and you say Oh scientists or
cause that and you have some rich here
you should state what triangle you're
talking about okay because more often
not and they're not in the questions you
are going to encounter you had multiple
triangles flying around right so if you
want to reference a ratio within a
triangle you should say which one so in
this triangle Oh a cute
I've got an able name that angle or
Center I'm going to name it the feet are
okay and then I'm simply going to have a
look at what tan and set are in these
drones in Australia okay so let's do ten
first it's easy to pick up okay which
sides am I looking at
I'm on opposite right opposite by
adjacent so the aqra right a cue but
this is the unit circle this is the unit
circle so therefore Oh a it's just one
right so just rephrasing this I can say
a Q equals ten feet well what is ank you
answer a Q is the tangent to the circle
created by this angle right if I we just
draw another one for you right
he's that's
if I put up for you okay he's a he's a
point right on the circumference okay
give me an angle right like say okay
that's a that's a pretty that's a pretty
wide angle in there okay let me make a
narrow one okay let's choose a feet
unlike say two to two degrees okay
that's twelve so if I go like that
let's call that twelve because I thought
your - okay I'm gonna have a line from
here the tangent up to when it collides
with that where that angle has been
formed right then this leg here will be
ten twelve it's the length of that
tangent okay clearly I could go off in
the opposite direction as well it would
just be double open right but the
important thing is it's that late for
some portion of that way so really tan
tangent gets its name for that tangent
to a circle and its length for a given
angle okay so where is sick now sick is
a reciprocal function SEC it's one over
cause because the third letter yeah so
therefore I'm gonna investigate cause
let's have a look at it in the same
triangle cos theta is equal to it it's
adjacent over hypotenuse right so it's a
adjacent over good yeah
now I already stated that a is just one
so if I rearrange this just a little bit
right babe that's one on Q so if I make
OQ the subject which is sick now what is
OQ and the answer is just like this is
the tangent I get from such an angle
right OQ let me get another comment
OQ is the secant right it's a secret
because it cuts right through the second
tangent to the circle okay so here right
see how I've got that twelve degrees
there all right well this length over
here will be the secret form a 12 degree
angle that's it